[Musique]
edouard sac ayant peint mais aussi
interroge un questionnement sur la
société un questionnement sur soi
l'artiste dit il dans ses toiles des
fragments de sa vie une rétrospective
comme une introspection
il ya des apparitions de mon identité et
à travers chaque tableau pas pour mais
reconnaître m sur tout d'abord pour me
connaître et à travers cette exposition
moi aussi je suis
dans une recherche de connaissances de
moi même comme les autres aussi une
centaine de toiles bigarrée aux couleurs
vives et pétillante des centaines de
regards de visages qui semble observer
les visiteurs edouard 5 à lyon invite à
se poser
la couleur alors représente la lumière
et la lumière comme une métaphore sur le
dire qu on met en lumière certaines
stations c'est à sion chacun les ppp les
compléter c'est cette machine un cours
un tableau et avec les couleurs et
toutes ces choses là on peut chacun
faire son discours
des toiles créé tout spécialement pour
l'exposition l'artiste grec mette en
place un labyrinthe de visages
tourmentés
[Musique]